[Music]
this is the only shopping list you'll
need for that special Xbox one gamer in
your life first of all make sure your
Xbox gamer has the latest console by
upgrading them to an xbox one s the
newest version of the Xbox one is 40%
smaller with an internal power supply
and up to 2 terabytes of storage plus
the Xbox one s has 4k blu-ray 4k video
streaming and HDR for the clearest most
realistic visuals yet the Xbox one S is
available starting at $2.99 once you've
got your console be sure to include an
Xbox one S vertical stand securely
position your Xbox one s console
vertically with the official vertical
stand from Microsoft an upright console
makes for the perfect setup taking up
less space get it for $19.99 of course
they'll need a controller so get the
best with the Xbox one elite wireless
controller the elite controller offers
high level customization to improve
performance and comfort it allows you to
choose from a variety of combinations of
thumb sticks D pads and paddles for a
more personalized feel fire faster with
hair trigger locks and improve control
with a rubberized diamond grip the Xbox
one elite controller sells for one
$49.99 typing can be time-consuming on a
controller make life easier with an Xbox
chat pad an Xbox trackpad plugs into
your wireless controller making
searching and sending messages faster
and easier the chat pad features a
backlit keypad and headset audio
controls it also comes with a chat
headset that plugs directly into the
chat pad get a chat pad for $34.99 for
streaming movies and TV shows the Xbox
one media remote should come in handy I
personally spend a lot of time streaming
media on my Xbox one so the meteor mode
is on my list too it's easy to use and
has backlit keys plus it stays on so you
don't have to keep turning on your Xbox
controller to control video playback get
a meteor remote for $24.99 the remote
works with two triple A batteries
next you can enjoy watching TV on the
Xbox one with the hauppage digital TV
tuner watch free over-the-air broadcast
TV on your Xbox one using this digital
TV tuner it connects to your Xbox one
via USB plug in the included ten-mile
antenna into the TV tuner run through
the Xbox TV configuration and start
watching HDTV get one for $59.99 if they
filled up their Xbox one with games and
need more storage supply them with a
Seagate game drive why delete games when
you can store more this two-terabyte
game drive lets you store up to 50 Xbox
one games the Seagate game drive is
compact and portable and perfect for
bringing over to a friend's house get
your own 2 terabyte game drive for 99
dollars you can use your Xbox one
controller on your PC with the Xbox
wireless adapter for Windows Xbox play
anywhere launched this year allowing
players to buy a game and play it on
both Xbox one and a Windows 10 PC at no
additional cost use an Xbox one wireless
controller on Windows PCs laptops and
tablets using this wireless adapter the
adapter supports up to 8 wireless
controllers and cost $24.99 and last but
not least don't forget a headset
turtlebeach makes great ones like the
xo7 pro the xo7 pro is good for both
casual and competitive gamers alike
it has crystal-clear audio and is quite
durable it features memory foam ear
cushions for comfort and noise isolation
it also has what it calls super human
hearing mode to pinpoint quiet audio
cues like someone reloading or
approaching you get an EXO 7 pro for 150
995 happy gifting i'm chastity and i'll
see you next time
[Music]